mein name ist willkommen liebe freunde
herzlich willkommen wir heute zum großen
staffelfinale von jodhpur hände in
meiner letzten action of tortur hände
wurde er das preisgeld was die singles
nach der ganzen show hier bekommen
wieder auf 75.000 dollar erhöht weil
harry und francesca eine nacht in der
provinz spielt ohne kontakt hingekriegt
haben und an der stelle
[Applaus]
ich bin so froh
ich auch da kann man aber die augen
aufmachen es war ein krasser test für
die beiden aber sie haben ihn bestanden
und gezeigt dass sie es ernst meinen
ich finds halt immer dann krass dass die
das jetzt so als volle heftige sache die
wir gemeistert haben festlegen
die haben einfach eine nacht
nebeneinander in einer suite geschlafen
ohne sich zu berühren so prodi habe
jetzt auch nicht des corona impfstoff
entwickelt habe glaubt ihr habt eine
tiefere emotionale verbindung von seien
absolut keine frage
[Musik]
ich habe auch einen guten witz wie nennt
man einen kleinen türsteher
sicherheitshalber hier direkt vergraben
oder da ich weiß ihr haltet mich für ein
witzbold trocken aber ich hoffe wir
konnten euch beweisen wie ernst wird die
ganze sache näher
das neu anfangen sehen ja
ihr habt eine nacht nebeneinander im
bett geschlafen
menschen einen meinen dass so ernst
hammer ist es nach gut kurs will weile
haben so sei auch immer
gut
was gut kurz das ist falsches deutsch
[Musik]
grünes licht
das heißt sie dürfen ich kann besser
küssen will herausfinden willst und
meine haustür ich habe ich werde
versuchen nicht zu kotzen ich glaube
jetzt kennt ihr alle themen
[Musik]
wer soll denn da für teams wie sein
was ist mit roller und schon heißt deren
team eigentlich schon das hört sich an
wie sonnen reißwolf so papier so so
klein machen wir auf einmal klein machen
diese erfahrung hat mir gezeigt dass ich
liebe will so sagt james bond auf wunsch
bestellt
ihr müsst euch halt nur überlegen die
leute dort bekommen einen kostenlosen
urlaub irgendwo wahrscheinlich in der
karibik und können nachher sogar noch
mit plus rausgehen wenn sie einfach
keinen körperkontakt haben und darstellt
wird diese leute die schwierigste
aufgabe der welt da das doch nicht
normal danke dass du dir zeit genommen
hast mich kennen zu lernen zu verstehen
wie kann man denn so krasse grüne augen
haben meine augen sind auch grünen aber
mein grünes er so ein müll grünbühl ich
und was ist mit den anderen 29 was ich
hier bisher gelernt habe
[Musik]
er ist sie überhaupt
diddy ist hier eine schlange oder was
rettet eure ehre
mir ist alles egal ein computer kann
mich nicht ändern ich habe alles klar
die hat sehr schöner blick schon an der
stelle die neun leute die dazu gekommen
sind haben einfach überhaupt nichts
dazugelernt
wo es jesus eigentlich noch könnt ihr
die kurve kriegen denn langer hat einen
letzten workshop für euch geplant in dem
es um neuanfänge geht harry was machst
du
also wir müssen jetzt anscheinend neuen
workshop machen und
nix und krank ich fühle mich richtig
scheiße so
frag dich mal
woran das liegt
meine werke
ich hätte nicht verstehen warum ich
leute abonniert haben aber wenn es noch
nicht getan hat dann macht es gern gar
nicht schaden
locker an kommt ihm eine
benachrichtigung wenn ihr so ein
meisterwerk online geht
sie sind hier in koppl an meiner stelle
heute verbinde ich mich nur mit dem klo
so macht auch sinn wenn man chloe h
[Musik]
zehn sekunden später
ich bin einfach volle kanone auf mosel
boden gefallen
gott okay mehr ahlmann geht echt nicht
lenas finaler workshop soll den singles
helfen negative labels hinter sich zu
lassen so
[Musik]
kann ich besser was abgeht ehepartner
soll die verletzten ssten worte auf eure
haut schreiben was
die verletzten worte auf die haut
schreiben ja ich kann hören wie wird
dann gar nichts stehen
ich bin ein star wie stahl hart wie
stahl deutsch kann ich auch herzlos
egoistisch sein die singles erkennen wie
sie im moment und juristisch regensdorf
das ist ein regelverstoß hier willst
dann chester plötzlich beim kloster
blutrausch ich glaube ich nicht dass es
zum kuss mit dem bz von unserem rapid
vornehmlich auf da ist die tür findet
ihr nicht nicht mehr gehabt ich auch
nicht so
guckst du dir jetzt wieder die sonne
durch
das kann doch kein stück nach hinten
losgegangen ich was die labels alle weg
so nachricht ich will auch in europa
sowie um 15 uhr 30
[Musik]
24 stunden noch moment ist das nicht die
eu
ja wir haben noch einiges zu gucken in
allerdings sind meine aufnahme ist auch
schon bei 45 minuten
von daher will ich sagen meine lieben
freunde ist das jetzt war die letzte
folge turtur hände auf die wir reagieren
aber noch nicht das komplette finale
es kommt beinahe wochen wenn ich meine
rexe allerdings gefallen hat dann das
gerne einen daumen hoch unserem video
hier da und schreibt immer und in die
kommentare mit welchen wörtern ihr
eventuell in der vergangenheit oft
konfrontiert wurde und dann können wir
als community als flug für euch ein
virtual hat geben und alles wird
hoffentlich gut
[Musik]